in this video i'm gonna explain every
beast titan in the history of attack on
titan
out of all the nine time shifters that
exist i say this one has the most
variety when it comes to the designs of
each user
as they all have their own unique animal
characteristics
in the opening for season two of the
anime we saw a bunch of creatures
including bulls elephants and their
freaking t-rex
and at the very least some of those
animals were previous beast titans
it's still not explained what determines
which animal you get but based on zeke
i say you either get your favorite
animal or an animal that represents who
you
are for example if jean had this shifter
then he'd be the horse titan for sure
and if sasha had it she'd probably be
the deer titan or a cow titan
or just maybe a giant lobster for the
beast titans that we probably know in
this series
i'll be explaining the backstory of the
user in addition to what makes their
title unique for the other beast titans
i'll be commenting on their designs
but bear in mind that there will be
spoilers ahead as it's necessary to
explain the things i just mentioned
as usual i'd appreciate if hit the sub
button as we are on that long road to
250k
and let me know down below which titan
you think i should do next
okay so the first beast title on this
list is tom cassava who was an eldian
researcher
and a member of the malian warrior unit
unlike most warriors
tom wasn't really a fighter and he
didn't aspire to become a titan shifter
until much later in life
the first time we saw this character was
during a flashback to gracie jaeger's
childhood
in which grisha bumped into tom on his
way to see the airship from their brief
interaction it was clear that tom
already knew who grisha was
and this scene occurred 12 years before
he became the beast titan
at some point during the following years
tom would remove his ldn armband and
leave liberio where he would then get
into a relationship with a malian woman
he hid the fact that he was an aldian
from his new girlfriend with the two of
them eventually getting married and
having a son together
things didn't last forever though as
while their son was still a toddler
tom's wife somehow found out that he was
an aldian which had terrible
consequences for everyone involved
realizing that both her husband and her
child were subjects of ymir
cassava's wife killed their son before
turning the weapon on herself
tom was the one who found their lifeless
bodies and the situation deeply
traumatized him for the rest of his life
with his family gone tom returned to the
internment zone in liberio
where he applied to become a warrior
candidate in his words
he wanted to be a warrior so he could
end his life in the grandest way
possible
because as we know titan shifters cannot
live longer than 13 years after they get
the power
due to the curse of emir when he was
selected as the beast titan
cassava's main job as a researcher was
to help mali better understand the power
of the titans
tom spent his years searching through
the memories of previous beast titans
in order to learn more about their
history and in turn he would then report
that information back to mali
through his research he discovered many
interesting facts about the titans but
there was one secret about the founding
titan that he mostly kept to himself
for the sake of not giving away
unnecessary spoilers i won't mention
what the secret is or who he told it to
or why he did that but when the relevant
episode comes out then i will be doing a
breakdown
in the manga it was revealed that
cassava had the sheep beast titan
and had an interesting design to say the
least its most notable feature were the
gigantic curved horns on its head which
would have been useful for ramming into
enemies if necessary
the titan had sheep's wall covering its
head in the upper part of his torso
while the rest of his body had bare skin
like the regular pure titans
you might imagine that a sheep beast
titan would walk on all fours
and while that is true for some of the
beast titans cassava's one did walk on
two legs
one thing to note about this particular
character is that tom claimed his titan
wasn't really useful in war
however when he said this i think he was
more talking about himself as a person
clearly with the right user the sheep's
titan could have been a massive force on
the battlefield but as i said
tom himself was a scientist and a
researcher so that's the reason why he
said what he said
the next person on this list is zeke
yeager who inherited the beast titan
from cassava in the year 842.
he was the son of grisha yeager and
diner fritz who are both prominent eldin
restorationists
and zeke's mother in particular was one
of the last remaining aliens with royal
blood
at the time of zeke's birth the goal of
the restorationist was to somehow
reclaim the founding titan from parodies
island
and then use its power to rebuild the
alien empire they didn't know exactly
how they were going to accomplish that
but a few years later mali announced its
own plans to invade paradise and acquire
the founding titan
grisha saw this news as an amazing
opportunity for zeke to fulfill their
goals
as by making him a malian warrior he
could infiltrate the island and steal
the founding titan
zeke felt an intense pressure from his
parents to become a warrior but his
heart was never really in it
his parents were solely focused on ld
restoration whereas zeke was just a kid
who wanted to be a kid
and he wished that his parents would
spend more quality time with him he was
shown to be jealous of the playful
relationship
that other sons would have with their
fathers and every night grisham and
diner would leave zeke at his
grandparents house
while they attended their restorationist
meetings any spare time zeke had was
usually spent studying the true history
of elder with his father
but as we've established this isn't
something he was motivated to do
this lack of motivation effectively got
him demoted from the warrior program as
commander mcgath didn't think that zeke
had the necessary passion to fight for
mali
instead of training with the other kids
he was forced to do odd jobs like
mopping up the floor but on one fateful
occasion he happened to run into cassava
tom liked to play with a baseball in his
free time and zeke just luckily walked
by at the right moment
the two got talking and eventually
became friends with zeke playing catch
with him quite frequently from that
point onwards
meanwhile the restorationists were
growing increasingly frustrated that
zeke showed no signs of becoming a
warrior
and grisha eventually lost faith that
his son could actually do it
this was a heartbreaking moment but zeke
realized that it was for the best
as despite his failure he could still
live a full life inside of liberio
that situation quickly changed though as
one day he overheard marion officers
talking about how they were close to
pinning down the earlier restorationists
zeke knew that if that happened he and
his entire family would be sent to paris
island where they would be turned into
pure titans
he subtly tried to warn his parents to
stop doing what they were doing
but he totally failed and at that point
he accepted that they were going to be
caught
cassava noticed there was something
wrong with zeke and the boy proceeded to
tell him the whole truth because
you know he had nothing left to lose
zeke promised that he'd still remember
the fun times they had
even after he becomes a pure titan but
tom thought of a way that they could
avoid that fate
he suggested to zeke that he turned his
parents into the authorities because it
would not only prove his loyalty to mali
but it would also save his grandparents
in the process
it's important to mention that zeke did
not want to give up his parents
but as their conversation continued tom
was able to convince the boy that it was
the right thing to do
i doubt pastor thought he would be one
day convincing grisha's son to snitch on
him
but life can be pretty crazy sometimes
during the years after his parents were
sent to parody's island
zeke began to regard cassava as his true
father unlike grisha
cassava made time to have fun with zeke
and actually viewed him as a person
rather than a tool that could be used to
free the ldm people
by the time tom was able to have a
successor zika matured into a
trustworthy and reliable warrior
candidate
who was then selected to inherit the
beast titan he also inherited tom's
iconic
glasses which is something zeke has worn
ever since we first saw him
in terms of design his beast titan was
most reminiscent of a monkey which is
not surprising when we consider this
moment
this scene right here was the beginning
of the end physique's childhood
as from that moment forward he would
basically dedicate all his time to
becoming a warrior
the last time he truly got to be a child
was in this scene before his parents
approached him about being a warrior so
i feel like it's only natural
that that's what he became at 17 meters
tall zeke is the second tallest titan
shifter only being beaten out by the
closest titan
and his disproportionately long arms
allowed for amazing throwing strength
given that zeke had been honing his
pitching skills for years with cassava
this beast titan could not have been
more perfect as an alden with royal
blood
zeke's beast titan also displayed
special abilities that would normally be
reserved for the founding titan
for starters he can turn people into
titans with a scream so long as they've
consumed his spinal fluid in some way
no titan shifter besides the founder has
ever been able to do that
but the madness didn't stop there as he
could tell these titans what to do and
have them obey his orders
everything considered zeke was the best
beast titan that marley ever had
until he traveled to paris and betrayed
them but what can you do
next up we're gonna be looking at most
of the notable beast titans throughout
history
however bear in mind that some of the
images on screen are from the final arc
of attack on titan
so if you don't want to know major
spoilers then i suggest you pause the
video now
the first ancient titan we should talk
about is the minus or beast titan
whose design is identical to that of the
mythical creature in greek mythology
the minotaur is a creature that eats
humans and has the body of a man
and the head of a ball and when we look
at the attack on titan universe it's
literally the exact same thing
just about 15 meters taller like zeke's
beast titan
it has fur around its head and neck area
as well as its legs
but most of its torso is totally bare it
also has a cool pair of horns on its
head
although i feel like cassava's titan was
better suited for ramming into people
moving on we have the snake beast titan
which is one of the few titans we know
of that is a reptile
it has scaly skin across its entire body
and although
its design is inspired by a snake it
still has a regular shaped torso like
most titans
we didn't see the lower half of its body
so in theory
it could have the lower half that's like
a snake and has you know no legs
um and you know what to support that it
was hanging upside down the first time
we saw it
maybe it's snaky lower half was wrapped
around something but anyway
in its mouth it has a forked tongue
which is just like snakes in real life
and its neck is capable of extending the
deer beast titan is next
and this is the first one on this list
that actually works on all fours
as you can see this thing is genuinely
just a massive deer
and has no human-like features
whatsoever in all likelihood this is
probably a good thing
as by being on all fours it allows the
deer to gather more momentum
before smashing into enemies with its
antlers the antlers can be hardened if
necessary
and unlike most beast titans it seems to
have fur covering its entire body from
head to toe
possibly the most hilarious titan in
this video was the bunny titan
because this thing had a buff body with
broad shoulders and muscles
only to have a cute little rabbit head
on top there was also a beast titan that
more closely resembled an ape than what
zeke's was that had proportionately
sized arms
and ape-like features on his face thanks
to falco we know that in history there
was a flying beast titan
but we don't know exactly what creature
it was for all we know the flying beast
tyson could have been a pterodactyl or a
seagull we just have no idea at this
point
what we do know is that falco's draw
titan is technically half beast titan so
consider this an honorable mention
in chapter 137 we got introduced to the
dog beast titan for the first time
which walks on all fours much like the
deer titan the dog titan has flappy ears
and a skinny body
but i personally don't know what breed
this is like i'm not really a dog person
even though i do have one dog butter i
don't really know the breeze too well so
someone in the comments please do let me
know
what type of dog is this now the next
part of this video was difficult because
there are a bunch of titans out there
that may or may not be beast titans for
example in one of my other videos
i said that this titan here was a draw
titan and i had people in the comments
agreeing with me
people disagreeing saying it was a car
titan and even more people saying it was
a beast titan
so the point is that there's a debate to
be had as to whether certain titans are
actually beast titans or not
in my opinion there are loads of titans
out there with animal features that
don't happen to be beast titans as there
might be other factors that cause that
that we don't know about with falco
being one example
for that reason i'll be saving many of
the titans to look like this for a
future card titan video
but in the meantime i figured i should
mention the underwater beast titans
during the opening for season two of
attack on titan we saw at least three
different
whales as well as at least one other
creature that lives in the ocean
a beast titan that could consistently
stay underwater would change naval
warfare
as most shifters are only good for
combat on land if mali ever had a whale
titan in the last 100 years
then enemy nations would have been
totally scared to use their battleships
as the world titan could annihilate them
at any second as i make this video there
are only two chapters left to go an
attack on titan
so i'm not confident of a whale titan
ever being seen
but you know it would be something cool
to explore if there was a spin-off
series about mali
or perhaps the great titan war let me
know down below what was your favorite
beast titan design
and be sure to drop a like as it does
help out the video until the next one
peace out